[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let me tell you right off that
I did not invent this field.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We've detected
gravitational waves
from this crashing of two
black holes into each other.
This is the beginning
of a whole new way
of studying the universe.
It's like Galileo using the
telescope for the first time.
What is a gravitational wave?
It's an excitation of
space and time together.
Nobody really believed
that you could ever
detect them because the size
of the effect is so small.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The idea was extremely simple.
What the gravitational wave
does is stretches space this way
and compresses space that way.
So you exploit that property.
Put one object here and
another object over there,
and let the gravitational
wave go through that system.
And it'll change the
space between these
by contracting that one
and extending that one.
And I came to the
conclusion that,
if you made this long enough--
kilometer scale--
you could probably
get these extremely
precise measurements.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I said, "Holy mackerel!"
We have shown that Einstein--
God knows how he got
it-- was right in 1915.
To me, that's a miracle
that that happened.
The man is thinking--
and I don't mean the theory--
but the elegance
in the experiment--
I mean, that is a human
endeavor that, I think,
everybody in the world
should be proud of.
Congratulations, we
are thrilled for you.
And we're thrilled for all
those who collaborated with you.
And guess what?
You know what I think?
You are the best of MIT, Rai.
Thank you and congratulations.